[Music]
do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you were put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the universe
me neither
but you know one can hope right
wave to Mommy because she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seem to recall you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it is I'm running a business
right now that business is getting a
journalist in and out of poundonia
[Applause]
no no and no
it was a journalist I have resigned my
position here Madison 20 grand says you
are
president finaga so nice to meet you
you must take a selfie you approved
oh
what the hell just happened you're one
man's security detail happened he's a
human I'm with the president of a
country in the middle of a coup this is
the scoop of a lifetime you got to be
alive to have a scoop for a lifetime
we never should have come let's go you
can't just leave him
[Music]
ready
I'm just doing my shopping
do you need help again
the time for coaching man
oh my God
Color Me impressed Mr petite
tell me you got that run
[Music]
on September 22nd
time for music We heard you this is
gonna be fun
and clear
please make Expendables for rated R
there better be violence and lots of it
I want all the blood and guts [__] it
first things first holy [__]
my mind is full of these brutal places
fantasies
[Music]
that will now become a headless reality
that's a great idea
well I don't play no more
hold on
you're my [__] kill me you're welcome
now that's what I'm talking about
good to be back
[Music]
enjoy the show
Expendables the
indefinitely
rated R
in theaters September 22nd
nine seconds
that's what I'll give you to decide your
fate
[Music]
what did you do back home
government work I'm retired because of
these people I'm beginning to understand
real peace they see you as one of us now
I believe this is where I'm supposed to
be
this happens to you many times the mafia
there's like cancer no cure
whatever you and your friends do do it
somewhere else you learn English I'm
preparing
is that a Time ax no it's a burger
it seem like a man who understands
violence
[Music]
I like this place you can't take that
from me
I can take anything I want
foreign
multiple dead bodies on that farm in
Sicily do you kill him
[Music]
do I look like a killer
[Applause]
hand
respecting anyone
I need to have an intimate under
wood and the bad
I promise it's confidential it's between
you and me do you feel happy here of
course I'm happy here
aren't you
do you feel you know how she would react
in every situation I've always had this
fantasy that there's something else out
there for me
[Music]
do you want to live mundane lives or do
you want to be part of something special
and unique
you've been selected to live up there
okay you're wasting your time because we
haven't even been on an airplane I
should I should clarify I'm talking
about you here junior
only
[Music]
we're going to ensure hen has company
while you're away
we're going to replace you
[Music]
I don't want a robot living with my wife
you really want to leave her here all
alone day after day
don't really see me anymore
I encourage you to use this opportunity
to act on your instincts
whatever we decide we'll be together
[Music]
I told you
I'm on vacation while I'm on vacation
I'ma just float come here Mr Parker
thank you Marcus and Emily Parker you
have failed to notify your airline that
you are registered sex offenders
[Laughter]
what the hell is wrong with you
look at us all together again we just
wanted to give you guys a real honeymoon
just found this crawling under our table
he's crawling
it's a prodigy it's amazing
I'm gonna place this nice
see what it's in here you didn't tell
they gonna be gone Bingo by the time I
get into my birthday you must be Mr
Parker apologies for the change in
schedule Mr Young is invited you for
drinks all of you gas I need you to be
really cool can you do that for me
[Music]
[Applause]
look who you're talking to when have we
ever not been cool
literally just released from San Clinton
I got you the best wedding present
why does this coconut taste Cokey
because it's your mom it's really kind
of beautiful if you think about it no
listen to her picture thing's going at
all it's cool Marcus is cool we're
floating right
get your hands off my wife
ever since she showed up he turned this
relaxing family vacation to total chaos
who does that
we have been through hell
why don't we just go back I knew it
chicken it's only one thing left to do
sir
I've never seen that much water come of
a person before did I throw a lot your
butthole threw up bud
[Music]
what you got here it's Habitat here's a
habitat for a baby here
sleeps over here beside the Rocks keep
it safe from Hunters smarter
[Music]
Elena Erickson what are you doing with
my house what's going on your father
Jacob Holbrook when was the last time
you spoke to him when I was 10 years old
I'm confused I thought your parents said
in a car accident that's what I told you
Holbrook he's the marsh King guy that I
heard about on the radio he and another
prisoner escaped last night
Jacob Holbrook the so-called Marsh King
abducted Beth Erickson and held her for
12 years in the wilderness with the
daughter she gave birth to while in
captivity hope I'm not trespassing or
anything
[Applause]
I think he's coming for me
I wish he would have told me the truth
he gave me this after my first kill
these were the only tears my father ever
wanted to see you'll always be my little
Shadow now I realized a person I
believed in the most was really a
monster this means we're family
it means owned not family don't confuse
the two
[Music]
what's going on Elena I feel like he's
here miracle
has that been in your room the whole
time
you must always protect your family
[Music]
it's me
is Where We Belong
I waited my whole life to see you again
I wasn't sure what I would feel when I
did
[Music]
I can still all be your family
so what's your big goal
dream I want to be an astronaut
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God
you're serious
okay
I wanted this for almost 30 years
every decision I've made I've made with
the Space Program in mind
who the hell are you I'm Jose Hernandez
sir I'm an engineer you're the new guy
right
that third floor mentor needs toilet
paper
it's a stupid dream last 10 candidates
were chosen from 12 962 applicants it's
never gonna happen
those people who got into the program
what do they have
that you don't
they have skills that I don't have
it's taken them years to get where they
are
but there's no guarantee
[Music]
I know this is hard on everybody
my body hurts I can't sleep I know I can
make this work
over the last 10 years I've applied to
the Space Program 12 times and I've been
on the verge of giving up after each and
every rejection but you know what sir
here I am
so you could turn me down again but rest
assured I'll be standing here again in a
year
we grew up watching our people make
sacrifices it's on us now
that he is a superpower
this may not be your future there will
always be your past who better to leave
this planet dive into the unknown than a
microphone worker
get into my eye
you're all the very best in the world of
what you do
I want you to know that this isn't your
typical contract
it's more like a competition to kill me
king of killers
or I can guarantee I will kill you
still on for tonight right 8 p.m at the
coal train anniversary is tomorrow
[Music]
don't worry baby I'll find out who did
this you're invited to eliminate the
world's greatest assassin those the
client drank us I'm in were they sending
in
welcome to Japan you set all this up I'm
your employer I work alone
nobody leaves until the game is finished
and we fight hard and Die With Honor
that's what I'm talking about he set
this whole thing up we have to change
the rules on that the only way we
survive this is if you work together all
of us versus you
[Applause]
dragons
told you I was competitive
[Music]
you sure you want a piece of that
who's next
who is it it's nothing oh dude it's Pete
oh my gosh that is pretty funny
you're in Salem they didn't teach us all
our history
some stories got lost along the way
maybe if they had dogs everything to
happen my brother would have left that
knife where he found it
I will play I won't quit
you know what I think we should do right
now go to the party come on let's go
if you play with me then I'll let you go
to your party and I won't call Mom okay
Joe
what game do you want to play
[Music]
duck duck goose
I will play I won't quit
tell me demon
am I it
morgas
what did you do let's play
Marcus
go what is going on it's not him it's
the knife
found you
hey buddy you're just messing with us
right how about something hey man you
know
it happens when it wins
what if we win only one way to find out
I will play
I will play it I won't quit
please
I won't quit
let's play a new game
[Music]
GTA five minutes to the war zone we must
foreign
[Music]
this Friday
Earth will never be the same
it's only a year it just wants to be
immersed in human Culture by being your
husband my pretend husband you have to
have sex with it or that is disgusting
it doesn't even have the equipment for
that
welcome home son come give your father a
hug that thing is not my dad
none of us were prepared yeah we just
have to adapt with our technology humans
can enjoy a new era of prosperity it's
not real food they print it do you want
me to cut that for you we would rather
live in a cardboard box and be some
gooey coffee tables [__]
disrespecting me
and look around the world unless if it
seems like a place anyone would want to
be at some point he starts being a
domination deep down in there they have
hearts I know they did I literally think
they don't have circulatory assistance
period
I don't know what to say to him
landscape with invisible hand rated R
only in theaters Friday
[Music]
[Applause]
took me to a few matches you don't see
him no more
oh
yeah see
[Music]
I've been doing real fights since a
couple of years ago I always cast this
around they don't see nothing else
you ever thought about being an exotico
[Music]
they don't let exoticos win I want to
flip it
tonight
this guy right here
[Music]
getting too big
each other
[Music]
a witness to history
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I was thinking tonight could be a good
night for sex night possibly
it's an interesting idea but you know
Thursdays
how's the new Opera coming along good
great great we had discussed seeing a
first draft of the score in two weeks
still all right I'm suffering from a
temporary blockage at the moment
no turn it back on
one
two five
is he all right he had a total breakout
after his last Hopper
I can't do this
we need to take a walk jolt your brain
out of its little rat pattern interact
with a stranger okay honey I have a
patient bye
are we going that way I keep imagining
you naked I don't know if you want to
hear more details about these images no
about every one of these people has a
story for an opera and then Levi what do
you do I operated Tempo the wrong hands
this tug is a deadly weapon
[Music]
I'm addicted to romance isn't everybody
I've been arrested for stalking I had to
go to rehab and uh I'm not supposed to
be doing this
I can't believe that actually happened I
mean she seduced me right she's a witch
the demented tugboat captain who knows
men to her Tugboat and kills them
beneath them I've loved it how did you
come up with that
I was really angry at you and now it
turns out on your Muse oh see I'll never
leave you
um I love cleaning cleanliness is close
to Godliness where my patients are
talking I imagine getting inside their
heads with disinfectant and just
scrubbing them down
your tugboat captain came to see me I'm
in Love no no just admit that I had a
magic effect on you my imagination came
up with the story my talent wrote the
music I mean you don't kill men and eat
them do you no I haven't yet
you know I can't resist a romantic story
even if I'm not in it
[Music]
what up adoronda
listen up
Squad game maybe uh zip it
can we just get you guys
[Music]
oh
let's go
welcome auditioners you guys are so
talented so unbelievable this will break
you this will fully destroy you
congratulations on being the most
talented kids
stoppage jiggle like a jackpot a jiggle
like a jackal these are the things we
can do with masks
weird
[Music]
if you drop a line or a note is a little
off key you crack or something what does
that say about you
Tad news I will not be doing piercings
anymore in the Hut because there's an
arc amongst us
um Cassie has narked
it's totally fine we're gonna need to
prioritize the musicals which means the
straight plays are gonna have to be
acoustic quick question what's a
straight play there are musicals and
then there are straight plays so then
what would be a gay play
Broadway
[Music]
we only have three weeks to create a
masterpiece it's on you know all on you
let's do this
[Music]
but only three percent of people make it
the rest end up in a mental facility or
on a go-go box in Hell's Kitchen
disaster everything is gonna be okay
we're theater people we know how to turn
cardboard into gold
[Music]
fun and games it's
inhale your past exhale your legacy
not too quick
[Music]
man in your head in your hands
take your time
[Music]
you want to know the secret
it doesn't end or begin
just changes forward
[Music]
welcome to day one at the Paris Opera
ballet school I can't believe I'm
actually here
good morning everyone there's been some
sort of administrative error you will
all re-audition for your place at the
Paris Opera ballet
good luck
she looks like a lost alpaca
what if I don't make the cut everyone
sent me home
wow can't believe your mum owns double
apothecary
what's that just some double your
recipes I guess
[Music]
hey why do you call your W recipe book
the book of Jones it's the book of
family spells you're a witch not just me
you we call ourselves Wizards come on
your magic is special you're one of us
we need you to start training now that's
what I'm doing at school
it's your birthday it's not something
you can walk away from weird because
that's exactly what I'm doing see
walking
stop off to the side CeCe you have to
believe you can dance
[Music]
I know I'm good enough
focusing on dance and only dance is the
only way this is going to happen you do
realize that
Double Double Toil in trouble
[Music]
the Wizards have been waiting for you I
have to focus on staying at this school
I'm not saving the freaking world
wait until you see what I have planned
[Music]
foreign